three of five Iranian Americans who were
moved from the Evan prison in Tehran to
house arrest on Tuesday they should
return to their families in the U.S in
the next few weeks this is a positive
step but I don't want to get ahead of
its uh its conclusion because there's
more work to be done to actually bring
them home my belief is that this is the
beginning of the end of their Nightmare
and the nightmare that their families
have experienced the U.S will release
several Iranians it held for violating
sanctions imposed on Tehran but perhaps
most important to Tehran officials six
billion dollars long frozen in a South
Korean bank will be transferred to
qatar's Central Bank Cutlery officials
will then release those funds only to be
spent on humanitarian programs inside
Iran experts say it's significant that
Tehran would agree to such a financial
Arrangement it suggests that Iran wanted
this agreement and wanted to de-escalate
tension somehow with the United States
and that it it sees this as a part of a
strategy of trying to recover
economically from the reimposition of
sanction from covid from everything that
Iran has gone through over the last few
years but let's not get too excited I
mean let's understand this is still the
Islamic Republic of Iran it is still
severely repressing its own people U.S
officials are clear the prisoner swap
does not mean relations between the two
countries are getting better we are not
in talks with Iran uh on the return to
the jcpoa the nuclear deal that's that's
not on the agenda right now what we are
talking to Iran about
particularly through our Swiss
representatives and our partners in the
region is getting these Americans home
we are still focused as we ought to be
on all the other destabilizing activity
that Iran is capable of and doing in the
region supporting Russia's war in
Ukraine supporting terrorist networks
throughout the region in the Levant and
then of course the the threats to
Maritime shipping in the in the Gulf
itself
one diplomatic step forward many more
steps still to be taken between two
long-time foes Rosalind Jordan Al
Jazeera Washington